what if you could have the latest iphone
for just a fraction of the price how
about the top of the line iphone for the
price of a month of netflix sounds great
right well according to a bloomberg
report this might happen sooner than you
think let's dive in and take a look
apple is reportedly working on a
subscription service that will let you
essentially lease the device and use it
as long as you want now i know what
you're thinking and yes a monthly
payment service for the iphone already
exists the twist here is that unlike the
iphone upgrade program where the cost of
the iphone is spread out over 12 to 24
months this new subscription model isn't
supposed to make you pay for the cost of
the iphone over an extended period of
time this service is cheaper e-waste
trust me i was just as surprised as you
are right now apple isn't exactly known
for how cheap its prices are so why the
sudden change of heart well there are
two answers to this question the first
is what apple is most likely going to
tell us and that is that they're doing
this to protect the environment and
reduce e-waste this is the same
reasoning apple presented when they
stopped including the fast charging
power brick with the phone and why the
new sim ejector tool in the iphone se3
is weird it's all because of apple's new
found love for the environment to be
fair e-waste is a big deal and the
subscription service where devices are
returned once users are done with them
would help with tackling e-waste on an
unprecedented scale apple decided that
they were going to be carbon neutral as
early as 2030 and this move is a big
step in that direction to make every
single apple product carbon neutral by
2030
even yours we're working to make every
iphone ipad watch and map with 100
recycled or renewable materials as of
right now only about 30 of iphones are
traded back in and this number goes down
to 10 when we look at androids phones
getting traded back means apple gets to
recycle components which in turn leads
to a lower manufacturing cost and a
higher profit at a lower price this
brings us to our second reason which is
some good old-fashioned money higher
profits
revenue is very good business it means
that income does not stop for apple this
is likely going to increase revenue over
time now you've seen peloton they're
trying this now according to
counterpoint research the average iphone
sale price is about 825
that means apple is generating a bit
over 800 from the typical iphone
customer every three years keep in mind
that this is only if a typical iphone
customer chooses to get a new iphone
every three years i know people that are
still on the iphone 7. so you might want
to take this estimate with the grain of
salt now in the bloomberg article mark
german did a rough breakdown of how much
apple could make using the new proposed
subscription model let's take the new
iphone 13 lineup as an example the
iphone 13 pro and pro max cost around
799.99 and one thousand ninety nine
dollars respectively using the same
monthly subscription price points that
the report used which in case you're
wondering are thirty five dollars forty
five dollars and fifty dollars for each
of the models here's how much apple
would generate over three years from the
monthly subscription compared with the
upfront price iphone 13 35 a month 1 260
over three years instead of 799
iphone 13 pro 45 dollars a month
six hundred twenty dollars instead of
nine hundred ninety nine dollars iphone
thirteen pro max fifty dollars a month
one thousand eight hundred dollars
instead of one thousand ninety nine
dollars see how much their profit
margins improved factor in the steady
stream of recyclable components they
would get in addition to these increased
sales profits and you can see why a
subscription model is actually a better
option for apple themselves better
option for consumers
this doesn't mean that the subscription
model is bad news for the consumer in
fact i actually believe that this might
be good news for both the consumer and
apple hear me out let's say that you
change your iphone after every three
years to do that you have to spend eight
hundred dollars now imagine that every
year you get the latest iphone and
instead of fishing out twenty four
hundred dollars you just have to pay
somewhere around twelve hundred dollars
that sounds like a steal to me the
latest and greatest iphone always in
your pocket for a small monthly payment
doesn't sound too bad you can just skip
a few expensive lattes a month and that
would cover the cost of your new phone
applecare
according to some sources it is expected
that this subscription will also come
with some of apple's other online
services included the entire package
might include extra icloud storage an
apple tv subscription and even applecare
these services will be available at a
reduced price in addition to the actual
phone and are expected to take apple's
profits even further up issues
sounds great right new iphone cheaper
too plus you're helping out with the
environment at the same time so what's
the catch well first of all this model
completely removes the ownership part of
well owning a phone out of the equation
and at the same time opens up questions
regarding privacy what would happen if
you don't pay the fee do they just take
the phone away or is there a fine all
these are questions that arise with the
subscription model but until more
information comes out there's sadly
nothing anyone can say in case you're
worried about the high price with no
actual ownership you should keep in mind
that it doesn't really matter you just
subscribe and at a price lower than what
it would cost you to buy the iphone you
can use it essentially as your own i
think that's a great idea and apple
could really hit a home run with this
one expected pricing
now what is the expected pricing of
these subscriptions i would place my
money on a number below 35 dollars a
month for the simplest plan and less
than 50 a month for the most premium
plan these numbers might be even lower
since apple's profit margin really is
just that high with these phones the
best deal in my opinion would be the one
that comes with a suite of apple
services most importantly apple care
included the rates for these would be
discounted in addition to the already
discounted prices of the phones and it
would overall be a great deal for the
consumer and depending on the price a
subscription might end up being cheaper
than buying multiple apple products the
iphone has historically been apple's
biggest money maker so any move that
improves the sales and the profit
margins of the iphone are a welcome
change following bloomberg's report
apple shares climbed to a session high
on thursday and closed up 2.3 percent at
174.7 cents apple has now posted eight
straight days of increases its longest
streak since november i can't say
definitively that this new service will
be worth it since there has been
absolutely no news about the expected
price but if the price turns out to be
in the same ballpark as most people
think it is we might just see a turn in
the tide when it comes to phone
ownership expected arrival date no one
at apple is talking about when the
subscription service might arrive
although rumors are that we might just
see it at apple's next launch event you
might be thinking that it's too early
for that but actually no the idea for a
subscription service for apple isn't
that foreign sanford c bernstein and
company analyst tony sekinagi pitched
the idea of hardware subscription in
2016. many customers would struggle to
think of a single possession they use
more than their iphone he said moreover
the cost of the iphone is a relative
bargain versus other services for which
consumers willingly pay if it turns out
to be true apple wants to let you
subscribe to its hardware products just
like you would subscribe to icloud apple
music or apple tv plus google has
actually been using this for their
corporate use based chromebooks so if
they can do not apple all in all apple
just announced what might be the biggest
news they've had since well they
announced the iphone apple is coming out
with a subscription model for their new
iphones for what is expected to be a
monthly payment of 35 dollars you will
be leased the latest iphone this move is
expected to reduce e-waste and help
apple skyrocket their profits the report
of this news helped apple record their
eighth day of consecutive rise in the
stock market and if all goes well we
might see this model being released for
use in at least america at apple's next
launch event fingers crossed this will
live up to the hype click a video on the
screen for more content like this and
i'll see you there